- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this month's
monthly inference colloquium
as part of our series
on trying to understand
the nature of correlation and causation.
And it gives me great
pleasure to introduce
our wonderful speaker for the talk today,
Dr. Eric Winsberg.
But before I give you a brief introduction
to his intellectual
trajectory and his work,
I would like to say
thanks to our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
who are unfortunately
not joining us today,
but their support of the Franke Program
and many other activities at Yale
is gratefully acknowledged.
So I also want to remind all of you
that we are recording this event,
and therefore all participants must
therefore mute their videos.
And as per usual and customary
at the end of Eric's talk,
we will have your questions,
which you can feel free to type up
in the chat as we go along,
and we'll have a Q and A
session at the very end.
So I also wanted to remind everyone
that in addition to today's lecture
in this colloquium series,
we have sort of the discussion session
that happens tomorrow,
at the same time, at 3:00 PM tomorrow,
we will have a discussion of Eric Winsberg
and the conversant this time is going
to be Dr. Stephanie Harvard,
who is a postdoctoral research fellow
at the University of British Columbia,
and in the faculty of
Pharmaceutical Sciences.
So first moving on to today's talk,
I just wanted to give you a brief sense
of Eric's intellectual path
and his research interests.
I first got to know of Eric
when I read his work on simulations,
really radical rethinking of
how to understand simulations
and modeling in the context of sciences,
and in range of sciences.
So Eric got his PhD from Indiana,
and following a postdoctoral
fellowship in History
and Philosophy of Science at Northwestern,
he joined the Philosophy Department
as a faculty member at USF,
and he went there in 2001
and has remained there since.
His principle interests are
in the Philosophy of Science
in particular, the
Philosophy of Climate Science
and the Philosophy of Physics.
He's particularly interested in the role
of computer simulations
in physical sciences,
and analog simulation in cosmology,
and in the foundations
of statistical physics
and the direction of time.
Many of you would have heard him,
he was our conversant with Carlo Rovelli,
which was sort of the
opening talk of our series.
He also writes on truth and
on scientific authorship,
it's a really wide
ranging set of interests.
He's the author of several
articles on all of these topics
that are appeared in all the top journals,
like Philosophy of Science,
Journal of Philosophy,
the British Journal for
the Philosophy of Science,
Studies in History,
and Philosophy of Modern
Physics and Synthese.
He has held numerous visiting fellowships
and has a lot of honors,
was a fellow at the
Institute for Advanced Study
at the University of Durham in the UK,
at the University of California, Berkeley,
at MCMP in Munich,
and the University of
Lunenburg in Germany.
So he has two wonderful
books, which are out already.
The first one is "Science in
the Age of Computer Simulation"
from the University of Chicago Press,
and "Philosophy and Climate Science",
which was published by
Cambridge University Press.
And he has a forthcoming book,
Cambridge Elements in
Philosophy of Science
on Modeled in Science.
Over the last year during the pandemic,
Eric has focused on the
use of models and methods
of causal inference in
the COVID-19 pandemic,
extremely important work
as many of you know,
that during the pandemic,
we really saw the provisional
nature of science,
and how we can draw limited inferences.
As we get to know more and
more about the disease,
we saw all of that play out
right in front of our eyes.
We all had front row seats
to how this was happening,
so really look forward to hearing Eric
some of your thoughts on this,
and hopefully you will cover
some of this material today.
So when he's not tapping
away on his laptop working,
you can often find` them on the water,
on the standup paddle board,
or that is the joy of people
who live in lovely climates.
What can I say?
Very envious Eric.
So the title of his talk today
is causal inference in
complex non-linear systems,
a cautionary tale.
So thank you so much, Eric,
for agreeing to speak in this series
and we are absolutely delighted
and take it away, please.
- Thank you Priya, I wanna
see if I can get this
Okay, great.
Just to give people a
little bit background,
Priya has already told
you that I've worked a lot
on Philosophy of Climate Science,
I finished my book up on
"Philosophy of Climate Science"
in about 2017.
And I was going out to California,
a year and a half ago.
And I wanted to start
thinking a little bit more
about how modeling can inform policy.
'Cause I've really been
focusing mostly just on them,
not modeling itself.
And I sort of started
to make that transition
to thinking more about having a more sort
of policy oriented focus to my research,
and that was in January of 2020.
And then we all know what happened
in the next couple of months,
which made it pretty obvious to me
that I ought to be focusing on this,
very new area in which
models were informing policy,
in a pretty quick and
impactful sort of way.
And so one of the things I hope
we can sort of get around to
in the session is talking about
what kinds of ways
modeling can inform policy,
and what constraints there ought to be
on models that inform
policy, that kind of stuff.
But because of the sort of
theme of the conference,
I wanted to just focus a lot on,
the theme of this series
being the relationship
between correlation and causation.
I wanted to focus on some of
the stuff I've been watching
about how we've made causal inferences
over the course of the pandemic.
And then I'm hoping like tomorrow
as Stephanie joins the conversation,
we can kind of broaden
the conversation back
to the general topic of
how models inform policy.
Okay, so let's see, how's this, okay.
So a lot of this kind of started early,
my interest in this kind of
started early in the pandemic,
and I had to go back
to the way back machine
on the internet to find this,
'cause unfortunately I didn't
screenshot at the time,
but this was the Financial
Times (indistinct) March 29th,
I think it is 2020, showing
us the course of the pandemic
in a variety of countries.
And what things I found
fascinating about this chart
was all these little blurbs
that they inserted here,
sort of explaining the
course of the pandemic
in all these countries.
So Italy had the highest death rate
because of a large elderly population.
South Korea had a low death rate
because of early large-scale
testing and tracing,
Spain locked down after 200 days,
but France locked down after 175 days,
and that's why Spain is a
little bit ahead of France.
Japan, I had to write this one in myself
'cause I definitely
remember this being on here,
but I didn't find the
version that said it,
Japan had a culture of masks and Bali,
and that was responsible for
where they are on the chart.
And a lot of what this
immediately reminded of was
an episode in the history
of climate science,
which kind of lasted from
about 1998 till 2012,
and it was known as the Warming Hiatus.
And there was a lot of
expelled over this hiatus
that was thought to have been
happening between 1998, 2012.
And you can kind of see it here, right?
So the green line is the concentration
of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere,
which all climate
scientists agreed results
in warming of the planet,
and yet this red line here,
which was tracing out the global
average surface temperature
of the planet seemed to
hit kind of a slow patch
in about 1998.
As you can see in the chart
between 1998 and 2012,
there wasn't a lot of net
warming of the planet.
And this caused a lot of consternation
among a variety of parties.
And people immediately wanted to know why,
why is there this hiatus?
And of course,
people who were opponents
of climate mitigation,
who were doubters of the
existence of climate change,
that clearly should be
a major problem, right?
So this was the Telegraph in 2006,
there is a problem with global warming,
and that it stopped in 1998.
And immediately I think
climate scientists felt
the need to explain this.
Why, why did the warming stop in 1998?
And there were, I think, sort
of two causal questions here,
two explanations.
One was why the slow down, right?
So just the brute fact that the warming
of the planet seemed to have paused maybe.
So just the brute fact itself.
And then there was this what was perceived
to be this modeling mismatch, right?
So if you look at this picture,
what you see the kind of
grayish black line here,
that's kind of heading inexorably upward,
that was the predictions
of the so-called the CMIP,
the climate model inter
comparison project,
which kind of averages together,
the forecast of a variety
of climate models.
And then all these little colored lines,
which are the actual datasets
of various meteorological
and climate agencies around the world,
like the Hadley center in
the UK National Atmosphere,
(indistinct) in the states.
So, there was this brute fact
warming seems to have paused
and then this modeling mismatch.
And the question was why,
and there were sort of a
variety of explanations.
This is from a paper in 2015 by Thorne,
and others kind of going through a variety
of plausible explanations
of why the pause happened.
Maybe it was variations in El Nino,
maybe it was some volcanic eruptions,
maybe it was quiet solar cycle,
maybe it was changes in
stratospheric water vapor.
So, climate scientists, I
think, felt the pressure
to explain this pause came up
with a variety of explanations.
And then of course, the other side said,
"Oh, they're just looking at
all these excuses," right?
So this is this kind of
notorious climate skeptic blog,
Watts Up With That?
And here you get from 2014 a list
of excuses for the pause.
Of course in the end,
I need to start to drag my
windows, I can see this.
In the end, as we look at
this, running all the way from,
let's say about 1900 up to the present,
you can still see this little pause here
between about 1998 and about 2012,
but in the great scheme of things,
it's pretty clear that nothing
particularly interesting
or important was happening here,
that was just maybe a little bit
of internal variability
swamping the overall trends,
so the clear trend here from
1900 to about 2020 is warming.
And you get in this spot 14 year period,
for whatever reason,
you get some internal
variability in the climate,
that is swamping the trends.
And then, also I think
one of the other things
that people sort of overlooked in,
if we go back and we look at this picture,
why is there this sort
of pause in the data,
like this very smooth
increase in the predictions,
the models, why don't
the models also predict
this kind of internal
variability you might ask
and he answered there, I
think it's also rather simple.
The sea map it's a climate
model inter comparison project.
So it's an amalgam,
average is over a variety
of different climate models,
and that's just apt to smooth out,
that just have to smooth it out.
Each model probably had a similar amount
of internal variability
as the actual day-to-day,
but when you average them together,
you got something to look
quite a bit smoother.
Okay.
So there was a rather simple
answer to the question,
why was there a warming hiatus?
And the real answer was, well,
it's a complex non-linear system,
and complex non-linear
systems just do weird things.
They behave in kind of sporadic
and jumpy and clumpy ways.
And there's a danger, right?
I think when you see the
behavior of non-linear systems
and that's gonna be one
of my main themes today,
there's a danger when you
see the erratic behavior
of a non-linear system to think
there must be an explanation
for these things.
I think we saw that happen quite a bit
in that period of climate history
when there was this analysis.
And so when I started
seeing these pictures
in Financial Times with
all of these explanations
of each one of these graphs,
it sort of set my alarm bells off,
maybe something similar is going on here.
And another sort of, I
think thing that we saw
in the climate hiatus cases,
that data rise is uncertain, right.
Data rise is uncertain.
And one of the things that drives all of
the mystery in this chart,
is that supposedly, sorry, supposedly,
all of these graphs supposedly,
are synchronized beginning
when the number of deaths
in that country reached 10.
But we now know, I think in retrospect
that this was all a fantasy, right?
We had no idea when
each of these countries
reached their 10th death.
There was a nice, recent,
really careful recent paper
in the journal of infectious diseases,
I think it was that I get so many people
have been doing now for months,
but did it very carefully,
and showed that by sort of
middle of January, 2020,
there were already cases
of COVID-19 infection
in six or seven US States.
So they just went and
looked at blood donors
from that period.
So, we really don't know.
We really don't know when
any of these countries
had their tenth death.
And so all of this lining
off and all of this,
like that was all relatively,
just an artifact of the way that
the data was being collected at the time.
We really don't know how to line up
these different countries with respect
to when their epidemic started.
And sort of over the
course of the pandemic,
we've been subjected to a
lot of causal inferences.
And I think one of the things that happens
when you have a lot of noisy data,
with a lot of clumpy,
pretty jerky behavior in it,
people will often find
what they wanna find
just as in the climate case,
people who didn't
believe in climate change
took that as an opportunity to say
that they were finding this.
So I think in the pandemic,
people have been able
to find what they wanna find.
So here's an article that ran
into a bunch of news outlets,
I think the associated press started this,
it's from right after the election,
obviously November 6th 2020.
And it tells us that US counties
with the highest virus surges
overwhelmingly voted for Trump.
And when this came out,
my first thought was okay,
well, maybe that's just some kind of
again just some kind of
spurious correlation here,
maybe there's something to this,
but then of course, once you've dug
into the data a little bit,
what you realized was that
it's true that the US counties
with the highest buyer surges
overwhelmingly voted for Trump,
but it's also true that the counties
with the lowest voter surges
overwhelmingly voted for Trump.
And there's a simple explanation for this.
And that's that the counties
that voted for Trump
were on the whole smaller counties
than the counties that voted for Biden.
Obviously we all know that rural
America tended to vote more
for Trump and urban
America voted for Biden,
rural counties are smaller,
small samples have more variants.
And so the Trump counties
tended to have either
very large numbers of Corona virus,
or very low numbers of Corona virus.
They just had the noisier samples and all.
And that was primarily
what was going on here.
And then we also, soon
we were looking at people
were trying to find
evidence of that various,
public health measures of
various kinds were effective.
If people remember this right,
but we very quickly went
from a pretty broad consensus
in say, February and March of 2020
among public health experts,
that masks were not really something
that the public ought
to be concerned about.
And then quickly that
scientific consensus changed,
and so there was a lot of
work trying to show this,
and a lot of it really kind of
was a pretty quick and dirty.
So this was a study that came out in,
it was published in October of 2020,
got reported in a lot of outlets.
This is a CNN article that's
referring back to this study.
And what was the study doing?
The study was merely going
back to kind of late April,
early May in the pandemic,
and it was sort of linearly
extrapolating these curves,
Well, linearly in the law of scale.
So in other words, sort of
exponentially extrapolating them,
and then just sort of trying to say,
okay, well, what's the
thing that happened right
before some of these
curves are turning down
oh, lo and behold, right?
Low and behold, it's masks.
So not really super rigorous way
of establishing causal hypothesis.
And you saw lots and lots
of studies like this,
where this was really the
method that was being used.
You would just get,
somebody would kind of take
a particular place, in this
case, it was the Delaware,
it was the Delaware
Department of Health data
on infections in Delaware.
And people just sort of putting
what they tend to be the dates
on which some of these public
health interventions happened,
and then trying to line them
up with bumps in the curve
where I pretty clearly see that you've got
just kind of a fairly
noisy and bumpy curve here.
And then just sort of trying to draw
causal hypothesis out of this.
And this was something that
I posted it on Facebook
just to make fun of this.
But so I'd been in California
until on June 15th,
we came back from California,
we returned to Florida,
and this was a chart of the
hospitalizations in Florida.
And it's very easy to just say,
oh, okay, here's when
Eric returned to Florida,
and look with what happened to
hospitalizations in Florida,
right after that.
But of course, that's not a
particularly effective way
of drawing causal hypothesis.
And, we were also, then I think,
we saw a lot of things like this happen.
So this was Scientific
American ran this story
in September 15th, 2020,
how New Mexico controlled
the spread of COVID-19.
So we were very eager to go find places
where it looked like there was success
in mitigating the epidemic,
trying to figure out
what did those places do,
and say, oh, okay that must be,
the fact that New Mexico
has controlled the spread,
they must have the secret
source for making this work.
And of course, this was one
of the most ill timed articles
of the pandemic.
You can see it here in a chart of
the case rate in New Mexico, right?
So here's, the article
comes out on September 15th,
how New Mexico control
the spread of COVID-19,
and then there's what happened
just a couple of weeks later.
Similar kind of event here,
here we have, this is an
article that ran in Germany,
it's Hamburg proof that an emergency brake
can get COVID-19 cases down.
So people thought, okay, look,
Hamburg is doing really well.
They must be establishing something,
must have some effective
method of doing this,
but of course, couple of things,
as we've made these things, this was just,
always these things tend to come out right
before things would get bad,
but sort of also, interestingly,
it's interesting, I think to line up
this is the ICU utilization
for COVID-19 patients
per million population
comparing the Hamburg
sort of administrative region,
what they call the Bundesland,
I guess the sort of Stockholm
County, Stockholm Lans.
And you can see, that pretty clearly,
whatever is going on in these places
is something fairly regional, right?
And so any attempt to kind of,
look for the interventions that Hamburg
was carrying out at these various places,
closing restaurants, having
mask mandates, closing shops,
making masks required in private cars,
having curfews, et cetera.
And you can sort of see,
people are going through this
and attributing these values
zigs and zags in the graph
to all these things.
But that we know that Stockholm
was not doing these things.
And given that Stockholm and Hamburg are
kind of proximal to each other,
have similar climate are
sort of under whatever,
whatever makes these curves come and go,
plausibly were being affected by them
in relatively similar ways.
We can see that it this is the course,
I don't wanna suggest that
I can make better inferences myself,
but it does seem sort of at
least prima fascia plausible
that means that these attributions
of the various zigs and zags and curve
to these interventions is spurious here.
We saw lots of cases like this,
this was a very widely
cited and influential study
by some Monica Gandhi here
is the last author on this,
but I suspect probably that's
one of his last author,
she was really the main author.
She was a major leader
in providing evidence
for the effectiveness of mask mandates.
So this was a paper that
posted on November 4th.
And the paper was withdrawn,
I forget exactly what the timeline
between occupation travelers,
but they withdrew it for...
They say, the author said,
what's drawn was (indistinct),
because there increased
cases of SARS COV two
in the areas we originally analyzed.
And it's like, the other thing,
they've taken some places
where there were mask mandates,
some places where they
were not mask mandates,
they've used very statistical methods
to show that the case rates
had grown in the places
where there weren't mask mates,
and hadn't in the places where there were.
But then within a month or two,
they had to withdraw paper,
because many of the places
that they were claiming
had been saved by the mask mandates,
were just catching up with
the places that didn't
have the mask mandates
a little while later.
And then one of the
things I wanna talk about,
especially this was a paper
that came out in December, 2020,
but I believe appeared in a pre performer,
a couple or maybe three months earlier
that used a method called
synthetic controls.
I wanna talk about a little bit today
to show that face masks had
considerably reduced COVID-19 cases
in the parts of Germany and
the Institute of Mathematics.
I mean, I think, again,
not that evidence kind of
seemed to evaporate over time,
but I wanna talk about this a little bit,
because early on we were seeing like,
the Financial Times thing where
just really sort of crude
causal attributions,
here, look, here's a chart,
this is because of the
culture of bowing or whatever,
sort of really very fast and
loose inferences like that.
Over time this method
of synthetic controls
became sort of really quite prominent
in trying to be more careful
in establishing these things.
So in that paper, by the screen,
you find this quite strong sentence,
which has a detailed
analysis of the timing
of all public health
measures in the region.
We studied guarantees,
that we currently tried
to our findings to face masks,
and not around erroneously to
other public health measures.
So we get to this in a bit,
but I wanna talk a little bit about
this synthetic control method,
and maybe suggest reasons
why it's not quite
the magic bullet that
many of the people who
were trying to use it over
the last year claimed it was.
This was another sort of famous pretty
widely shared headline
that this was a based
on a study that used the
synthetic control method,
that tried to show that the
Sturgis Motorcycle Rally,
which happened in South
Dakota in June, I guess,
was responsible for maybe May,
was responsible for a large
amount of that spread.
You may remember that the upper Midwest
had had its big wave right
around the time of this Motorcycle Rally.
So, okay.
So I just wanna step back a little bit
and talk about non-linear phenomena,
and why, just sort of illustrate
that non-linear phenomena tend
to have interesting patterns
that don't really call for explanation.
So this is maybe one of
the most classic examples
of a non-linear phenomena,
this is a double pendulum,
it's a pendulum on the
end of the pendulum.
And when you watch
something like this swing,
you can just see that it just goes through
these moments where it
kind of spins loudly
and then kind of slows down a bit,
and then will swing loudly later.
And anybody who watched
something like this
and thought, oh, I wanna try to explain
why at eight seconds into it,
it starts spinning furiously,
and then 12 seconds into it,
stops spinning furiously.
If you had a wild imagination,
you could imagine coming up
with all kinds of explanations
for why this kind of thing is happening,
but it's the nature of
the double pendulum,
and it's part of the nature
of being nonlinear system,
that it just exhibits these quite
interesting sporadic things.
And this is actually a simulation
just because fluids are a little harder
to visualize than pendulums,
but you can see that's a real data too.
This is so-called
Rayleigh-Bernard conduction,
in our collection where you
have a hot plate on the bottom
and a cold plate on the top of some fluid
and pretty quickly, you can see that
all kinds of interesting
patterns start to form,
and anybody who was not familiar
with what's going on here,
and wanted to then explain why
is there a dark red patch here
and a dark blue patch here?
And why is this thing displaying
all the patterns like this,
you can kind of get a global account
of why it has the sort of general,
why it's got a generally
sort of Eddy-ish structure,
but if you tried to explain,
why is there a big red Eddy here,
and a big blue Eddy over there,
you'd be pretty quickly getting
yourself into trouble here.
Okay.
So just a few things I think worth noting
about non-linear systems,
we just know this from the stay
of a wide variety of systems,
they can display abrupt transitions
in responses to small changes, right?
So if you had two fluids
next to each other,
one that was exhibiting
shallow convection,
and one that was
exhibiting deep convection,
an inexperienced observer might think
there was some deep
substantial causal factor
responsible for that difference, right?
They would look at these
two convective systems,
and say, look they look
radically different,
there must be some explanation
for why this one's
undergoing deep convection,
and that one is undergoing
shallow convection.
But the only explanation
that there would be,
would be a very microscopic,
and very cognitively unsatisfied one.
It would be if you could, in fact,
if you really had an unbelievably
detailed logical system,
you might be able to track it down
to some very small difference,
and identify what that
small difference was.
It wouldn't be due to nothing,
but it wouldn't be the
kind of thing that somebody
who's experienced and he was
looking for some of that.
So similarly learnt, right?
We know that avalanches can be
caused to get a pile of sand,
one very ill placed screen added
to an otherwise stable pile
can cause a massive avalanche,
perhaps more relevant to pandemics.
We know that if you have
like a lot of sub nodes
and you just assign random
connections between those nodes,
and then you look at
how many paths there are
from the top to the bottom,
very tiny change in the
probability of connections,
can sort of massively
give sort of big quality
of changes to the number
of paths that you'll find
between top and bottom.
So a lot of times I sort
of take on lots in here,
is that a lot of times these
kinds of behavioral changes
that you see in non-linear phenomena
cry out for explanation,
even though the true explanation
is often microscopic, nearly
impossible to identify,
and I think really, I would
say cognitively unsatisfying,
just in the sense that
it's not a kind of thing
that as human beings, when we encounter
these kinds of phenomena,
it's not the kind of
thing that we typically
are inclined to attribute
the explanation to.
It's just a picture of Jupiter here
with it's famous red spot,
which is just another one of these
sort of coherent structures that emerges
out of a nonlinear system
that, if you wanted to know,
if you lived on Jupiter and you wanna know
why is the red spot here?
You would not get a very
cognitively satisfying answer.
Okay.
So one of the main take
home lessons here at the top
is when you have these
three things together,
a system that exhibits a
fair degree of non-linearity,
a sort of rich causal
menu available to you,
think of the original, a
little Financial Times chart,
who locked down when, who
has a culture of mask wearing
and bowing, who had an elderly population,
who was using custom trace,
who was doing,
So you have a sort of rich causal manual
you're gonna appeal to, right?
And something that, I think this
is famous anthropologist
Evans Prichard noted this
when he was studying the
(indistinct) in Africa, right?
That's a pretty common
feature of human beings
that when people get sick,
or when bad things happen to people,
they immediately are
looking for explanations
in the form of why here, why now?
Why is this happening to me,
why is it happening here
not there, what's going on.
I think when you get these
three things together,
non-linearity, a rich causal menu
that you can appeal to,
to explain those things.
And a sort of urgent desire to know
why is the pandemic bad
here, but not there?
Why is it happening to us, but not them?
Why were they saved and we're not?
I think these three things together
often lead to dangerous inferences.
And just to give you a
little taste of this,
as I started thinking
about this I was like,
there's gotta be a really
good example of this
from the history of science.
And the thing that occurred to me as
I was thinking about
different non-linear systems,
earthquakes, of course, the
results of non-linear phenomena
and there was a whole
industry in sort of late,
mid to late 19th century
of trying to understand
what caused earthquakes.
Again, because earthquakes
displaying exactly
this kind of clumpy non-linear based
kind of dispersion of depth.
So you got all these people in
the late 19th century arguing
about, is it due to atmosphere pressure?
Is it due to the seasons?
Is it due to the position of the moon?
Is it due to the position of the sun?
And I think much like
many of these things,
not only do you, in these cases have
this kind of record data with all kinds
of you have a large causal menu, right?
All these people are like looking at what,
they wanna know what causes earthquakes.
And they immediately imagined
these are the things that
might be causing responsible,
they're not the plausible,
atmosphere pressure,
position of the moon,
position of the sun, tides,
things like that.
They have this messy clumpy data,
and then of course what we now know too,
is that their data were bad.
First of all, they didn't
know, as we now know
that most of the earthquakes on the planet
happen underneath the oceans.
So they were missing at
least 70% of the earthquakes.
And you get a lot of disagreement
between the scientists that all boils down
to they're looking at
different data, right?
So you have one person
saying, "Oh, you know,
"it's clearly the position of the moon."
And then someone else using
their data saying, "No, look,
"I can clearly show that
there's no relationship
"between the moon and earthquakes."
Okay.
But these were 19th century rubes,
we have much better data than they had.
We have much better methods
of inference than they do,
surely we can do better.
And surely we can identify the causes
of differential outcomes in the pandemic.
Well, a number of things
I think are finally here.
So I just wanna show you a
nice little picture that I like
this is based on, so Oxford
has been running this
since pretty early in the pandemic.
They've been tracking what they call
a stringent fee index
for different places.
That's meant to be a sort
of one number summary
of how aggressive public health measures
have been in various places in trying
to control the pandemic.
And you can plot them here
for at least the US states.
So, here on the horizontal axis,
you have this Oxford stringency index
averaged over March, 2020 to May, 2021.
Here you have COVID-19 deaths, 400,000,
The size of the blob is the,
so California's the biggest blob.
Texas is nice and big.
Hawaii is a tiny little dot.
The red states are red.
The blue states are blue.
The purple states are purple.
We all know what that means.
And you know, if you look at this,
at least to the naked eye, it looks like
maybe there's some
interesting patterns here,
maybe there's some degree
of covariance here,
but it's not entirely obvious,
but what's interesting,
is the various ways
that people can kind
of cherry pick examples
and make the cherry
picking with plausible.
So this is, I think you saw a number like,
we heard a lot about this about,
people arguing about Sweden a lot
over the course of the pandemic,
and the argument was always right.
Well, what's the relevant
comparator for Sweden?
Is it the European average,
or is it, you know,
it's Scandinavian peers?
And just sort of how you
decide that question,
is gonna determine what you think
the (indistinct) of Sweden is.
If you think the relevant
comparative for Sweden,
is its Scandinavian peers,
well then looks like Sweden was a disaster
relative to its peers.
If you think Sweden's comparator
ought to be European union as a whole,
Sweden's kind of in
the middle of the path,
despite having not really, you know,
Sweden would be very low
on this stringent index.
I forget what I should
have looked up there
with their actual volume of (indistinct).
I guess it's down here somewhere
in like Missouri or something like that.
But then here's what's interesting, right?
If you kind of play this
game of thinking that,
you know what the relevant
peer comparators are,
you can show all kinds
of interesting things.
So if you pick North
Dakota and South Lake,
well, surely those are good comparators,
okay, well, they don't really have
the very different stringency index,
but to the extent that they do,
it looks like stringency
led to more deaths.
Maybe you think what about
the Pacific Northwest?
How about Oregon and Washington?
Again, you can find the opposite of what
you would think is the
prima facie (indistinct).
You can pick Alabama and Mississippi,
pretty clear those are peers, right?
So the point here is like,
you see a lot of this,
I think people play a lot of this game
of like, oh, well, we can figure out
what the relevant peers here are,
and in the process of
that, we can make this.
But again, this is just
kind of a cautionary tale,
and this is a kind of dangerous game,
if you don't know how
much people are sort of
loading the dice when they
choose these comparators,
people are liable to be able
to demonstrate anything,
anything they want with
comparisons like that.
Okay.
So what are the sort of
most sophisticated methods
that we've had available to us
over the course of the pandemic,
for identifying what are
the causal determinants
of different outcomes that
we've seen around the world?
I should put them into two categories,
we've had sort of sophisticated
statistical methods,
and then we've seen some
nice chance to use modeling.
So it's kind of some things
like the Imperial College Model
that we're originally intended to forecast
what the pandemic would do,
being used retrospectively to explain,
why they did the things that they did.
Okay.
So statistical methods.
Here's the game, you wanna know,
did an intervention have
some causal outcome,
so, you wanna know, you know,
when kids go to private school,
and they're better at Math,
the kids who go to private
schools do better on Math tests.
Okay.
So what's the simplest thing you can do?
You can look at kids
who go to private school
and kids who don't go to private school,
and see whether the kids
in private school do better at Math,
but obviously, what would you find?
You probably find, oh yeah,
the kids private school do better,
but It would be because
those kids were wealthy,
and wealthy kids on average,
like tend to have a lot more other
educational opportunities,
and they tend to have a lot of things
that inhibit their educational growth,
like not having healthy breakfast,
or, you know, having, you know,
but the obvious point that
there are lots of things
that could cause wealth to
lead to better Math scores.
Okay.
So obviously you can't just look
at whether kids in private
schools are doing better
than kids in public schools.
Well, you'd ideally
like to do those right.
take a whole bunch of kids
and randomly assign them
to private school and public school,
but you can't do that.
You can't do that, I mean,
well, you could do that maybe,
but nobody's done this,
probably a lot of people
that raise apple flags,
if you tried to do this.
So what you can hope to
do is you can sort of
hope to wait for natural experiments.
So maybe you can wait until, I don't know,
Cleveland one day, decides it needs to do
a specialist remediation
of public schools.
And so it hands out
vouchers to all the kids
to go to private school,
then you can maybe look and see well,
did the kids who got
vouchers in Cleveland,
did their Math scores suddenly go up?
Probably pretty effective,
but you can imagine
somebody having the worry.
Well, I don't know,
maybe it just so happened
that at the time that these
vouchers were being given out,
maybe it just so happened that everyone
was getting better at Math.
Maybe that was the exact time
when the school house
rock episode came on TV
that was making everybody better at Math
all at the same time.
So how do we know that it's the vouchers
and the kids going to private
schools that are doing it?
Well, here's ideally
what you'd love to do,
you'd love to be able to say, okay,
let's look at the county.
I think it's Cuyahoga County,
I can never pronounce that right,
Cuyahoga County, which is
where Cleveland is in like
probably (indistinct) that,
and maybe hopefully you could look at
when the vouchers get handed out,
to the public school kids in Cleveland,
you could compare, you're not just looking
at whether they're doing better at Math,
but you could look at how much
better they're doing at Math
compared to how the kids are doing
in the suburbs of Cleveland.
So the hope would be there,
if it's not the vouchers that are making
the kids do better Math,
but it's some like
underlying trend in the data,
by comparing how much better
they're doing in Cleveland
than they are doing in the suburbs,
You'd be teasing out exactly
what the contribution
of the going to private school is.
And this is what's known
as the difference in difference method.
Both Cleveland and its suburbs
have some non-stationary
data, it's changing over time.
There's some difference,
but you're looking for the
difference in that difference.
You're looking for how much did
the Cleveland Math scores change,
relative to what the overall trend was
in the county as a whole?
But crucially what this requires
is that overall you have
what's known as the park side.
Overall you have what's known
as the parallel trends assumption,
it requires that whatever
is going on in Cleveland
and its suburbs is the same,
except for the introduction
of the vouchers
to go to the private school.
Okay.
Synthetic control methods are not really
that interestingly different
from difference in difference methods.
When you first read about anything,
this is like the sort of magic bullet
that enables us to do
what might be harder,
because sometimes it's hard
to find comparators there
where parallel trends are in place.
So what synthetic control method does
is rather than comparing the place
where the intervention happens,
to some particular
comparator use something
like machine learning to blow
the synthetic comparator.
So here, just this nice little example.
Here's this place Salta,
that's introducing a new tourism policy.
It's trying to determine
whether that tourism policy
is leading to increased
employment in the tourism sector.
And all these little groups,
so here's when the intervention happens
on the dotted line, right?
Here's a black line is Salta's
tourism employment level.
And these gray lines are just a whole set
of comprehend comparable places
that didn't have a change
in their trust and policy.
And when you do this, you try to find
a subset of these places,
and a weaving for them that produces
this synthetic comparator here,
and that's what this
little dotted line is.
And then the hope is that
this little dotted line
will be very close to what Salta was like
prior to the intervention.
And then if that's the case,
maybe you can attribute
whatever difference happens, sorry,
whatever difference happens afterward
as being attributable
to the tourism policy.
But crucially the parallel
trends still need to be in place.
Okay.
Parallel trends still need to be in place,
you've been able to make
yourself a synthetic control
that looks a lot like your
target area private intervention,
but in a way, the synthetic
control method enables you
to hide differences that were there,
that look like you try to
get almost a perfect match.
That might be just because
the machine learning method
is a really good way of data
mining for a perfect match,
even in spite of an
absence of parallel trends.
Okay.
So this is nice paper
that was written right
before the pandemic started
by one of the developers
of the synthetic control method.
I just wanna read you a
couple of passages from it.
It says synthetic controls
provide many practical advantages
for the estimation effects,
policy interventions,
and other events of interest.
However, like any other
statistical procedure
and especially for those aimed
at estimated causal effects,
the credibility of the
results depends crucially
on the level of diligence exerted
in the application on the method,
and on whether contextual
and data requirements
are met in the empirical
application at hand.
And this article emphasize the notion
that mechanical applications
of synthetic controls
that do not take into account
the context of the investigation,
or the nature of the data
are risky enterprises.
And that'll be in particular identifies
to sort of crucial visitor
honor that needs to be in place
for the synthetic control method to work.
On the one hand, it's advisable to select
for the donor pool,
that's the bunch of places
you're gonna machine learn
synthetic control out of affected
by the same regional economic
shocks, is economist,
as the unit where the
intervention happens.
On the other hand, if spillover
effects are substantial
and affect units in close
geographical proximity,
those units may come up biased estimate
of the counterfactual
outcome without intervention
for the unit affected by the intervention.
So think of it this way,
you wanna know, let's say, Jena
this was the mask study in
Germany (indistinct) they chose,
Jena as a place where this
mask mandate was introduced,
you wonder whether the
mask mandate led people
to like cases to go down, okay.
But you're worried about
the following thing,
it's plausible that when a
unit introduces mask mandates,
places around in the proximity of Jena,
people will start wearing masks,
'cause they see their close
relatives living in Jena.
they have friends in Jena,
they commute to Jena,
and some of them come back.
And so you get spillover
effect of mask wearing,
in the region surrounding Jena.
At the same time, you wanna make sure
that you are sampling from
someplace regionally close
because we know in retrospect,
if you think back to that sort
of Stockholm Hamburg chart
that I showed you,
we know that parallel
trends wildly breaks down,
as you get geographically far away,
if you compare Stockholm and Hamburg,
even though maybe
Stockholm was much closer
to let's say Florida in terms of what
the public health interventions
going on in there were,
you're gonna see a lot more similarities
between the Stockholm and Hamburg,
Stockholm and Florida
for whatever reasons,
I don't wanna pretend
to know what they are,
for whatever reasons
climate networks spread,
whatever it is, whatever
causes geographic distance
to result in different outcomes.
You're gonna see different things there.
So you kind of have these two desiderata,
and they really, I think
in epidemics anyway,
they really fundamentally conflict.
Because one that I wanna make sure
that the members of my donor pool
are not being affected
by spillover effects.
I wanna make sure that my donor pool
that I'm comparing Jena to
does not include any places
where the residents would be seeing
the people in the unit putting masks on
and wearing masks themselves,
but I also wanna make sure that
whatever region I'm looking at
is geographically closed enough,
that the kind of thing that we expect
from non-linear phenomena
where there's just,
clumpiness in the data causing
waves to appear regionally
and all kinds of ways we
can't hope to understand,
certainly not in immediate
ray as they're happening,
so we need to be careful about that.
And then timing is also crucial in this.
So if you go to look for
example, at the Jena paper,
when they sort of put up at the end of
they ran the study at first,
and they didn't find the
effect that we're looking for,
And then they said, oh, well, actually
it's because we didn't
realize at first that
when you have a mask mandate,
and the government announces
that the mask mandate
is gonna come into place,
people will start wearing
the masks before the mandate occurs.
So immediately now you've introduced
to the grid of flexibility,
and it's no longer obvious exactly
when this dotted line is happening.
And if you allow yourself some flexibility
in deciding when the dotted line happens,
then you really got
yourself into a situation
where you have a tremendous,
what I would call a Duherm problem.
Duherm was the guy that taught us
that when you're trying to
test the scientific hypothesis,
it's a bad thing, if there
are too many flexible ultra,
auxiliary hypothesis that you need
to connect the data to your hypothesis.
So if you have too much
flexibility in deciding
what the actual impactful
date of a mask mandate is,
that's gonna really sort of
hurt the inferential power
of your study, okay.
I wanna kind of wrap
up here pretty quickly.
So I'm gonna skip a couple of things here,
and just kind of get
to my conclusion here.
Here's I think my main conclusion, right?
So non-linear phenomena often
create illusions of patterns
that require explanation.
I think we saw this both in
the case of the warming hiatus
in climate science.
And we saw this happen in
sort of week after week,
month after month, over
the course of the pandemic,
people sort of trying to
make causal inference,
in the UA as things are going on,
as the phenomena themselves are unfolding.
And I think that's a specially
sort of epistemically rescue,
when you have these
normally in your phenomena,
and creating these patterns
that have the illusion
of a prior explanation,
and you're trying to do the
causal inference on the fly,
and you don't have the requisite.
If you think about the thing
that Abi is telling us about
the synthetic control method, right?
He's basically warning you,
if you don't have a good handle
on what's causing background noise,
and causing zigging and zagging,
you cannot use this method.
And I think pretty obvious
in retrospect at least,
that we just didn't have that kind of grip
on what was making the various features
of the data about those
inferences be present.
So, we just didn't really
have the opportunity
to have the kind of grip on the data
that Abi is warning us
there that we have to have
to use these kinds of
causal inference methods.
And I think, this is
especially epistemically risky
when the decisions that
are being supported
by those differences are
particularly high stakes.
And I don't need to argue for the claim
that we made a lot of decisions
over the course of the pandemic
that were pretty high stakes.
Okay, great.
Thank you all, I think I'll stop there.
- Thanks so much, Eric for
that wonderful presentation.
Dissecting many of the plots and graphs
that we've all been witnessing
over the past few months,
and puzzled over how do you
sort of policy decisions
were supposedly guided
entirely by the data,
but it's quite clear that
the underlying complex
non-linearities make it not so simple
to go from the data to policy decisions.
And I think the point that you were making
about the masking was
particularly interesting,
because of how initially I had gathered
that the not emphasizing masking
had to do with the fact that there
was a shortage of N 95 masks,
because the public was buying them up
when medical staff needed
it, healthcare workers,
frontline healthcare workers were,
there were shortages for them.
So it's very interesting how
all these kinds of
external factors play in
along with what the data is telling us,
thank you so much for that exposition.
And I'd like to open up the floor now,
and we have several questions.
Ty, did you wanna read the first one.
- Yep. Sorry, just unmuting here.
First one, yep.
So do you think we make
peace with the linear system
for using it to pin down
conditionally sufficient
causal factors and history,
and other social sciences to
pin down necessary factors.
And do we use non-linear
for the prediction process?
- I'll have to see if I
can look at that myself.
- It was up a higher
back at the beginning.
- So do you think we make
peace with the linear system
or using it to pin down...
- I'll tell you what I'll copy it.
- Yeah, I think I see it here.
Can you flush that out
for me a little bit?
I'm not sure I quite get the question.
We make peace with linear systems.
- Eric, I'm an economist training,
and we use linear system all the time
to pin down causal factors.
But what you are saying is totally valid
given that we live in a
very, very complex world.
So it seems like non-linear system
is more, more appropriate.
- [Eric] It depends.
- You know how to parse out the reality,
that's complex reality.
And that's when the
linear system helps us,
you know, to sectors.
- No, I don't doubt
that 10 years from now,
we'll be able to sort
through all this data
and we'll be able to learn some things.
But it's gonna require,
sort of the main point
of the (indistinct) paper to be,
you can't do this kind of causal inference
until you have a pretty good handle
on what the background noise looks like.
And so trying to do the
stuff kind of on the fly,
in June, July, August, September of 2020,
as I pointed out, like I came back
from California to Florida in June,
at that point, neither
California nor Florida
had really had very much
infection at all, why?
I mean, we don't really
know it could have been,
some people think it's
because of the climate,
once maybe we we've seen
the whole thing unfold,
we'll be able to tease all this out,
and we'll be able to do
the kind of inference
where you are able to
hold everything fixed,
or at least convince yourself
that you're using a sample
where everything is relatively fixed.
But by doing this in March,
April, May, June, July of 2020,
I mean, obviously we were gonna do it,
it was sort of baked into the cake
that we were gonna do this,
but it also should have been,
I think, made a little
more clearer I think,
that this was hard, we didn't know enough
about what the relative
peers to compare to was,
we didn't know enough about what was,
it was just a massive data coming in,
and we were making inferences too fast.
- Eric I take your point that the timing
of your returning to Florida
and the rising hospitalization,
I mean, I think one of
the intriguing things
about the pandemic has been how,
as you were pointing out, we were trying
to find reasons before the
phenomenon actualized fully.
So for example, prematurely
people were coming
with explanations and writing articles
about how come Indians, for example,
why were the few cases in India?
And maybe it's vitamin D
because it's a hot country.
Maybe this, maybe that, I
mean, there's so many trees
were felled for hypothesizing about this,
and less than two months later,
the pandemic came roaring back in India
with the variant rendering
all of those speculations
completely moot.
- I mean there's something known
as the sports illustrated curse.
I don't know if people know what this is,
and the idea is that if you
get a picture on the cover
of sports illustrated,
you're gonna go into a slump afterwards.
The obvious explanation of that
is that sports is (indistinct) reverting.
You're gonna end up on the cover
when you're at the end of a hot streak,
and you're gonna mean revert.
The worst thing that could
happen to you in the pandemic
was to be on the cover of
scientific American as like,
look how well India is doing,
look how well New Mexico is doing.
That was the sports illustrated curse.
It was guaranteed, if somebody
wrote you off as a case study
in how to manage the pandemic,
that within two months tops,
you were gonna be a poster
child of what not to do,
we watched this happen week after week,
and month after month, yeah.
- So there's a very interesting question
from Carl (indistinct) who asks,
in terms of policy recommendations,
how do you avoid causal
attribution errors,
and what I mean, what
flows from your analysis?
- Yeah, I mean, I just thought
this right from the get go
in the pandemic and I
feel quite vindicated
in my belief in this early on,
that we should have been listening
to the sort of conventional
wisdom about epidemics
and how to manage them,
and this business of trying
to figure out on the fly,
what was working and what wasn't working
was not a good idea.
So, I mean I'm not very smart
and I'm not a statistician,
and I'm not the one that's
gonna be able to do this,
but I'm reasonably confident that
there are smart people out there
who as I said down the road,
will be able to tease apart what happened,
but it's gonna take years.
And it seemed me foolish to be
every month revising what guidelines were
in response to inferences
that were being made
on the fly like that,
even the normal procedures of peer review,
we all know that ordinary peer review,
it's not what secures the
reliability of science,
much more in-depth
criticism has to take place.
And just to referees,
before we get good science,
but not even that was in
place in much of the pandemic,
it was stuff being uploaded
to pre-print archives,
and then making the New
York Times two days later.
And, yeah.
- I think this was a perfect storm
of journalistic exuberance coupled
with as you said,
pre-prints would come out
hypothesizing stuff and not
peer reviewed in detail,
not corroborated with
other independent analysis
for cross checking, et cetera.
And yeah, but yeah.
- And politics. I mean
everybody had convictions
about the nature of the pandemic
that were linked to politics.
I mean, that's why I kind of started
with the Trump voting counties.
I mean the Motorcycle Rally,
there were some just
sort of transparently,
I mean, maybe those weren't really like,
being done by rigorous
scientist or anything like that.
But pretty clearly, people
were eager to hear that,
whatever their political convictions were,
those were virtuous and led
to good health outcomes.
When you think in retrospect,
now it kind of looks
like that seems unlikely.
- So there's a really nice
question from Chris Mink,
hi Chris, delighted that you're here.
And his question is what is
the scope of your criticism
of causal attribution?
You've given various cautionary tales,
but is your claim even stronger,
that we have not, or
maybe even cannot make
any justified causal claims regarding
differential performance due to the MPIs
in the pandemic, take the Sturgis Rally
as a concrete example,
which was in August, 2020
and brought between
450,000 to 500,000 people
from over half of all US
counties to a week-long event
with no mitigation measures in place.
Do you think it's impossible
to make any causal claims
regarding the role of this event?
- Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely impossible.
And the studies that claim to do this
were ripped apart by
smarter people than me.
I mean, yeah, that's not, no way.
So again, as I said, I
think like eventually
Rayleigh's methods will be able
to tease apart some of these things.
- But Eric, I mean the role to play
for super spreader events,
I mean, super spreading
events are real, right?
- Yeah, they might be,
but I mean, they might be,
but okay, I mean sure.
But being able to look,
I'm not denying that
when people get together
for a motorcycle rally,
they're probably gonna
spread some disease.
But the idea that you could tease out
as was done in some of
these studies tease out
the actual number of cases to--
- Attributable I see--
- Yeah actually and then measure
the economic damage of it
and again, I think in retrospect,
I think it's reasonably clear
that it just so happened
that the Sturgis Motorcycle Rally happened
in a part of the country
that was due for their wave.
I mean, I'll put it this way,
if you think that the Sturgis
Motorcycle Rally caused
all the cases that were attributed to it,
then in some sense you
have to factor things
that were it not for the
Sturgis Motorcycle Rally,
the kind of plain states
would have somehow
been magically spared from COVID.
I mean, that's a fact we're
being asked to believe,
if you actually think that that's
what the motorcycle rally did,
then in some sense you think buff for it.
But in the end we sort of
know that like every state
had its, other than like a
few really small outliers,
like Maine and Vermont and Hawaii,
and Alaska, every state
eventually kind of got its due
in some sense.
So it seems implausible
to me that like people
were able to... And then
if you actually look at,
what they did to try to show that,
I mean, I'll send you stuff.
- No, but I mean, I was curious about,
there were also these cases of churches
where people were singing
and it was shown that
exercising your vocal chords
in that fashion kind of
spread the air walls,
what do you make of those kinds
of super spreading events?
They were many too, I mean--
- I honestly think
we're gonna have to wait
and see on a lot of this.
I do think a lot of that stuff
was kind of cobbled
together pretty hastily.
- Priya would you like me
to take the next question?
- Yeah please go ahead.
- We're going down the
line from a participant.
I would like to know
if it would be possible
to understand COVID as a black Swan,
is it possible to cross data from natural
and social sciences?
Is it not a risk in
I think constructing
artificial parallel trends?
- Let me see if I can read
that one that says that from.
- Further back, sometimes it's not easy
to scroll through the chat feature,
here, I'll just post it again.
- Well, certainly, I mean,
certainly it's a black Swan
in the sense that I
understand the black Swan
is just something that nobody
would have expected to have happened.
So certainly it's a
black Swan in that sense.
Is it possible to cross data
from natural social science?
Yeah, look, I mean, I'm reasonably hopeful
that in the long run as I said,
we'll be able to sort
through some of this,
we'll be able to disentangle
what some of the natural causes
were from what, or just being,
natural non-linear variability, et cetera,
but not yet, I don't think so.
- Okay, next question begins
with the favorable comment.
Thanks for the fascinating talk.
What evidential role do first
order causal/mechanistic
explanations play in non-linear phenomena?
For instance, let's say that prior
to doing a large scale tourists program,
there was a small focus group that showed
that the intervention is
effective on a micro scale.
Does this have any evidential value
that the tourist intervention will
have some efficacy when
put out on a large scale?
- I mean that just case by case, right.
I can't answer that generally.
But I think often in the
case of like epidemics
what's usually going on
with something like that
is something that's being
tested in a kind of,
micro clinical setting,
and then being extrapolated
to a social setting.
So, you might do something
like put masks on mannequins,
in a room and have them
spray aerosols on it
and see what portion of
the aerosol is trapping,
but it doesn't tell you
whether you're preventing
a minimum infectious dose from
getting to the other person.
It certainly doesn't
tell you anything about
what mask mandates do in
terms of mask wearing.
You could be a hundred percent
convinced that mask wearing
reduces spread without
believing that mask mandates do
particularly maybe if you
thought that masks wearing
for, so again, I think this is right.
That's the sort of standard
view in clinical settings
about N 95 masks was you
should have gone into a room
with one of them hoping
that it will protect you
for more than 20 minutes.
That was I think the usual guideline,
like go in there, wear your N 95 mask,
and get out within 20 minutes.
Why?
Not because N 95 masks
only last 20 minutes
or something like that.
But because people are not very good
at not sticking their fingers in there
after about 20 minutes.
What about people who were
working eight hour shifts
with the mask?
So yeah, I mean, obviously
you can get causal information
from these abstract settings,
like putting masks on mannequins
and seeing what kind of
aerosols come through them
or whatever,
but getting from there to knowing what
the actual impact of let's say,
a mask mandate on an entire municipality
or county or state or whatever,
it's gotta be not just for one day,
but for months, right?
Again, remembering that
like, if this was a marathon,
not a sprint, maybe something
that maybe protected people
while they were complying perfectly
for a few days might not have had value
over the course of the months does,
not need stopped enforced or whatever.
So I think, there's a little bit of,
you can glean from things like that,
but I mean, there's a
reason why, for example,
economists like to look at
the difference in deference methods
rather than just focus groups
or something like that,
because it's difficult to extrapolate
from those contexts to broader contexts.
- But Eric, what do you
make of the six feet
in the social distancing?
Do you think that was--
- I thought that was well
understood to have been made up
and not particularly, my
understanding the latest
while we spoke is that,
it's more about a number
of people in the room,
how much time they spend in the room,
the quality of ventilation in the room,
and not so much about, it's
not like in other words,
I thought the consensus
now was not so much
that I don't just directly
transmit the virus to you,
I can fill the room up with it.
And so the six feet, I think
most people started thinking
it didn't matter that much.
- Okay.
And the last question I think
we have in the list here,
what about things surfaces
versus airborne transmission
building on what you were just saying
that the latter is more important.
Airborne transmission strikes
me as something most of us,
myself included feel like we've learned
over the course of the pandemic,
and which has informed
reasonable changes of course,
when it comes to mitigation strategies.
So focusing less on
cleaning, for instance,
more on ventilation, indoors and outdoors,
the concrete version of
the question just asked,
did we have no reason
for making those changes?
- So, I mean, those are quite different,
I mean, so I think at the surface thing,
like we know like that's pretty clear,
like floor mites I don't
transmit corona virus,
it's just like the
washing of your groceries,
all that was for nothing.
I mean, that's like you can ruling out
a potential causal mechanism,
it's whole lot easier.
I mean, it's not easy.
It will still take us a few months,
I take it or whatever, but that right.
And separating again,
whether it's six feet
versus filling with a room thing,
I mean, those are things
that you can determine
in a microscopic context.
Like those are sort of
basic mechanical facts,
even I think determined in
the microscopic context,
but that's quite different from,
you can make guesses from facts like that,
to what interventions
are gonna do socially.
But social interventions are
unbelievably complicated,
I mean, again, this was
something that I think,
it was widely known and understood
among public health experts
prior to the COVID-19 pandemic,
that closing schools for more
than six weeks is ineffective.
Why?
Not because of anything you could learn
by watching what happens
with kids in school,
and the way the virus is, no,
because kids are kids, and
they crave social interaction.
And if you close the schools,
they eventually start
congregating in other ways.
So, I like to remind people that the deem
and epidemiology is from
the Greek word for people.
And it's the things that
we're talking about here
are not just microscopic facts about
how the virus is transmitted,
we're talking about like, what happens
when you institute public health measures
and you then have to wait and see like
what people are gonna do.
That's very different
than being able to predict
what will happen if people
actually do exactly what you say,
which never happens.
People don't do exactly
what you say, never.
That's not how policymaking works?
When you're evaluating
a policy intervention,
you don't just imagine that
everyone's gonna do exactly
what you tell them to do,
'cause they aren't built that way.
- So I guess there's one
final question has come in.
And the question is that it's been usual
to miss cultural issues
when news presents data
on how to think about cultural traditions
that make for difficult comparisons.
How does one take that into account?
Do we need observations from
other feeds like ethnography?
- Yeah.
This was another thing
I think that set me off
early on in the pandemic
about this kind of stuff.
So I was in California early,
and we started seeing
early on in California
that like Latino communities were having
more infection than
non-Latino communities.
I started seeing people talk about, oh,
it's because, fill in the blank about
how the Latino people behave.
And I just thought (indistinct),
my wild guess isn't because
these people have jobs
that don't allow them to work over zoom,
let's not leap to like stereotypes about
how various ethnic groups
like comport themselves.
And so that was one thing
that I think set me off
kind of early about, like,
let's not be super hasty
in making these causal attributions.
- But on the other hand,
I mean it is undeniable
that communities of color
were hit much, much harder,
both economically, epidemiologically,
and in terms of, we already knew
that the medical care
for these communities
is not as robust as it is.
- Absolutely, I mean, this
plus I never seen this
I think maybe how to do
that asked a question,
and then they pointed this out to me,
somebody did early on that the number
of hospital beds per capita in Manhattan
was like three or four
times higher than in Queens.
And lo and behold, they were bad.
Were the hospitals in New York
overwhelmed than in Queens?
And of course also ran,
I mean, that policy,
look, I mean, these policy interventions
were being made by wealthy white people.
And so they were, a lot of them
were designed to protect us.
We were the ones deciding
what were essential services
and what weren't essential
services, et cetera, et cetera.
And then of course also in US particularly
among African-Americans obviously,
we unfortunately have kind
of preexisting bad health.
That's obviously the results of various
other racial qualities, et cetera.
So there's a whole
complex mixture in there,
but I really doubt, I mean,
I shouldn't say I doubt,
I should just say you'll
be on my back harder,
to think that what's going on there
is something like, oh,
it's because Latino
people behave this way,
or it's because black people
behave that way or whatever.
Like, let's leave that for last.
Yeah.
- And curiously, that seems
to be where people go first.
- [Eric] Yeah, of course, of course.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
So if there are no further questions,
Ty do you see any, I think.
- I think we got them all, I think.
- So, thank you so much,
Eric, for this wonderful work.
And we really look forward
to the discussion tomorrow.
- It's gonna be great, (indistinct),
it's gonna shift gears to a much more sort
of broad spectrum look at things.
So, I think people don't wanna miss that.
I think Stephanie's stuff's gonna
be super interesting tomorrow.
- So thank you everyone for attending,
and Stephanie, we're
really looking forward
to the discussion tomorrow.
Thanks everyone.
And see you at 3:00 PM tomorrow.
Yeah.